Hallo zusammen!
Heute gibt's eins meiner liebsten Gebäcke zum Winter hin, wir machen nämlich leckere Kokosmakronen!
Es gibt schon ein Rezept von mir, das ist sehr alt und es ist auch eine andere Zubereitungsweise
und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht zeige ich euch auch mal die klassische, nämlich mit der Baisermasse.
Und wenn ihr jetzt so ein paar Tipps und Tricks von mir beachtet, dann gelingen sie euch zu 100% mit Kiki Garantie!
Wir starten jetzt mit dem Eiweiß, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
So ich nehm' mir jetzt mein Eiweiß, das Wichtigste hierbei ist, dass ihr das sauber trennt.
Es darf nicht mal 1 Gramm vom Eigelb mit dazu weil sonst lässt sich die Masse nicht gut aufschlagen.
Was auch sehr wichtig ist: Wenn ihr jetzt eine Küchenmaschine nehmt oder euer Handrührgerät,
darf hier nichts an Fettrückständen sein! Keine Butter, kein Spülmittel, nichts einfach!
(Hamza: Also schön sauber spülen bevor man das benutzt!)
Richtig schön sauber spülen!
Das gebe ich jetzt hier rein mit dem Schneebesenaufsatz.
Da gebe ich eine gute Prise Salz dazu,
fange an das zu schlagen, gehe dann auf die höchste Geschwindigkeit
und dann gebe ich meinen Zucker da rein und lasse das richtig schön fest schlagen, das wird so ca. 5-6min mit der Maschine dauern.
Jetzt könnt ihr noch Aromen und Geschmäcker hinzufügen, ich hab mich heute für Vanille entschieden.
Was auch sehr gut passt ist z.B. Zimt
oder - das habe ich jetzt aber nicht da, sonst hätte ich das vielleicht auch benutzt - Bittermandelaroma!
Diese kleinen Fläschchen, diese - eigentlich schmecken die nicht wenn wir ehrlich sind!
Aber 1-2 Tropfen könnte man hier auf jeden Fall reintun bei Kokosmakronen,
das ist so die einzige Ausnahme wo es passen könnte aber eigentlich schmecken die Null!
(Hamza: Aber wenigstens bist du ehrlich!)
Ja ist wirklich so, die schmecken halt einfach wirklich Null!
So und jetzt verrühre ich das mit meinen Kokosraspeln
einfach mit einem Teigschaber, jetzt könnt ihr nicht mehr mit der Maschine weitermachen.
Und dann ist eigentlich unsere Basis auch schon fertig!
Die Makronenmasse habe ich mir jetzt in meinen großen Spritzbeutel gefüllt.
Vorne dran eine Sterntülle, die verlinke ich euch natürlich in die Infobox.
Und jetzt geht's darum, das Ganze aufzuspritzen und da gebe ich euch einen richtig coolen Tipp!
Also nicht ganz am Backblech quasi ansetzen sondern so ein bisschen in der Luft.
Das zeigt der Hamza euch gleich mal am Besten von Nahem.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man's so gut erkennt aber in der Luft ansetzen
und dann so ein bisschen was rausdrücken und dann schnell abziehen.
*seufzt*
Tja Leute, es ist so wie's ist: Manche sind schöner und andere sind nicht so schön!
Ist halt so! Aber ist nicht schlimm, dafür ist es halt selbst gemacht!
Und ich gebe das jetzt so ein den vorgeheizten Backofen. 150° C Ober- und Unterhitze, wir brauchen's diesmal nicht so heiß.
Und dann dauert es je nach Größe so ungefähr 16-20min.
Es darf nur an der Oberfläche leicht goldbraun sein. Nicht zu dunkel, sonst werden sie zu trocken!
Und anschließend tunke ich wenn sie abgekühlt sind den Boden nochmal in geschmolzene Kuvertüre, das ist aber optional.
Aber ich persönlich mag's sehr gerne. Und dann sehen wir uns nachher nochmal. Bis gleich!
Die Kokosmakronen könnt ihr erst wirklich in die Hand nehmen wenn sie kurz abgekühlt sind.
Dann in die Schokolade tunken und nochmal auf Backpapier komplett abkühlen lassen.
Und dann sind sie schon fertig. Ich schreibe euch raus - rein?
in die Infobox wie viele bei mir rausgekommen sind.
Oh mein Gott! Okay, es ist schon spät!
Ich möchte das Video auch gar nicht so lang gestalten weil das ist wirklich ein schnelles, kurzes und knackiges Rezept!
Und daher verabschiede ich mich jetzt schon von euch!
Wenn euch das Rezept gefallen hat, dann hinterlasst mir einen Daumen nach oben
und ein kostenloses Abo, dann verpasst ihr nämlich meine Rezepte auch nicht mehr.
Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo. Tschüss, eure Kiki!